♪ ♪
>> Tucker: OUR OWN
DR. MARC SIEGEL TOOK A BREAK
FROM HIS MEDICAL PRACTICE IN
NEW YORK AND WENT TO WASHINGTON
THIS MORNING TO INTERVIEW THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE PRESIDENT
RATHER AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
HERE IS PART OF THEIR
CONVERSATION.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, GREAT NEWS
TODAY ON VACCINES.
BY HIS OR HER WITH A VACCINE,
100 MILLION DOSES PURCHASED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
$2 BILLION.
IT SEEMS LIKE THERAPEUTICS AND
VACCINES ARE REALLY PROCEEDING
AT A MAJOR SPEED TO.
>> THEY HAVE DONE REALLY WELL.
I WANT YOU ALL THE TIME.
YOU ARE MY GUIDE TO THIS BECAUSE
FRANKLY YOU HAVE A GOOD TAKE AND
YOU KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS.
THE VACCINES ARE DOING WELL AND
THERAPEUTICS.
YOU TELL ME, BUT I WOULD ALMOST
PREFER THERAPEUTICS FIRST.
YOU GO INTO THE HOSPITAL AND YOU
MAKE PEOPLE BETTER.
WE ARE DOING VERY WELL WITH
REMDESIVIR AND OTHER THINGS.
THE STEROIDS ARE TURNING OUT TO
BE GOOD.
PLASMAS TURNING OUT TO BE GOOD.
WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS PROGRESS
AND THAT IS WHERE YOU SEE THE
DEATH NUMBERS, A HORRIBLE THING
TO SAVE BUT THAT IS WHERE YOU
SEE THE DEATH NUMBERS REALLY
LOOKING MUCH BETTER.
>> MORE ON VACCINES.
I’M CONCERNED ABOUT FAXING
COMPLAINTS FROM THE COUNTRY.
30% SAID THEY WOULD NOT TAKE THE
VACCINE.
AS COMMANDER IN CHIEF END OF THE
FREE WORLD WOULD YOU CONSIDER
ONE OF THE FIRST TO TAKE THE
VACCINE TO SEND A MESSAGE TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC?
YOU KNOW HOW IT WORKS IF I’M THE
FIRST ONE HE SO SELFISH HE
WANTED TO GET THE VACCINE FIRST.
OTHER PEOPLE WOULD SAY, HEY,
THAT IS A BRAVE THING TO DO.
I WOULD ABSOLUTELY IF THEY WANT
TO MEET YOU AND IF THEY THOUGHT
IT WAS RIGHT I WOULD TAKE IT
FIRST OR LAST, MARK.
YOU KNOW IF I TAKE IT FIRST FROM
EITHER WAY I LOSE ON THAT ONE,
RIGHT?
IF I TAKE IT FIRST.
IF I DON’T TAKE IT FROM HE
DOESN’T BELIEVE IN THE PROGRAM.
BUT WHATEVER I THINK IS BEST IN
WHATEVER WE AGREE IS BEST, I
WILL CERTAINLY DO THAT.
>> I WILL MAKE A DEAL.
I WILL TAKE IT.
>> WE CAN TO GET TOGETHER.
>> TALKED ABOUT LOCKDOWNS.
I AM DISTURBED THAT YOU MORE
THAN ME DISTURBED ABOUT THE
ECONOMIC PHYSICAL, MEDICAL
LOCKDOWNS.
THE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS ARE
TALKING ABOUT LOCKDOWNS.
WHAT IS YOUR VIEW?
>> YOU CAN ALMOST SEE IT ON
TELEVISION.
I WATCH THESE GUYS -- WELCOME I
WON’T SAY BECAUSE IT’S NOT
SOMEBODY YOU HAVE A LIKING BUT A
CERTAIN COMEDIAN LOCKED IN HIS H
TIME.
AND HE’S LIKE WITHERED AWAY.
HE’S LOST THE WHOLE DEAL.
HE’S LOST THE WITH, SO MUCH.
I ALMOST WOULD LIKE TO USE HIM
AS AN EXAMPLE BUT YOU CAN USE
MORE THAN HIM.
IT IS HURTING PEOPLE.
THESE LOCKDOWNS ARE HURTING
PEOPLE.
WE DID THE RIGHT THING.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU AGREE BUT I
THINK YOU DO.
WE CLOSED IT DOWN.
WE UNDERSTAND THE DISEASE AND WE
DIDN’T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THIS.
IT CAME IN AND WAS NEW.
WE BANNED CHINA FROM COMING AND
WHICH IS A BIG MOVE.
DR. FAUCI ACTUALLY SAID I SAVED
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF LIVES.
IF YOU REMEMBER, I WAS ONLY ONE
THAT WANTED TO DO IT.
NOBODY WE HAD AN OFFICE OF 21
PEOPLE AND THEY SAID NO, BUT
I’VE GOT TO DO IT.
AND THEN WE BANNED EUROPE FROM
COMING IN WHICH IS GOOD WITH
ITALY AND ALL OF THE PROBLEMS.
BUT WE DID IT RIGHT.
WE CLOSED IT UP, NOW WE ARE
OPENING.
WE HAVE LEARNED, FOR INSTANCE,
WE LEARNED THE ELDERLY,
ESPECIALLY AND YOU CAN SAY THIS
BETTER THAN ANYBODY, THE ELDERLY
WHO HAVE DIABETES OR HEART
PROBLEMS, HAVE A PROBLEM, THEY
ARE REALLY SO ACCEPTABLE.
WHEN PEOPLE LIKE TO COMPARE IT
TO THE FLU, IT IS INTERESTING
BECAUSE I SEE THE FLU NUMBERS
AND THEY ARE VERY BAD, BUT WHEN
I LOOK AT FLU NUMBERS.
I NEVER LOST ANYBODY TO THE FLU.
I HAVE NEVER ALL OF MY LIFE,
I’VE HEARD MANY PEOPLE HAVE THE
FLU, THE FLU.
BUT NOBODY DIED.
I NEVER REMEMBER ANYBODY SAYING,
YET THE FLU AND DIED.
I HAVE LOST FIVE PEOPLE,
PROBABLY SIX, ACTUALLY AS OF
THIS MOMENT, I THINK PRETTY
SOON.
BUT I HAVE LOST FIVE FRIENDS
THAT WENT IN ABOUT ONE OF THEM
TESTED COME A GREAT GUY STANLEY,
ONE OF THE TOP REAL ESTATE
PEOPLE IN NEW YORK.
A GOOD MAN TOO.
NEVER INTO POLITICS UNTIL I RAN.
HE BECAME A POLITICAL WILD MAN.
HE LOVED IT.
A GREAT GUY WITH A GREAT SPIRIT
SET I TESTED POSITIVE.
AND I SAID, WELL, THAT IS TOO
BAD AND YOU WILL BE OKAY.
HE WENT TO THE HOSPITAL AND TWO
DAYS LATER IN A COMA.
HOW WAS HE DOING?
HE’S IN A COMA AND TWO DAYS
LATER HE DIED.
YOU KNOW, THAT HAS HAPPENED ON A
NUMEROUS OCCASIONS.
PROBABLY HAPPEN WITH PEOPLE YOU
KNOW TOO.
I NEVER REMEMBER ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
IT DIDN’T.
I NEVER REMEMBERED THIS
HAPPENING WITH THE FLU.
THIS IS A SERIOUS THING.
BUT WE LEARNED PEOPLE, STANLEY
WAS AN OLDER GUY.
HE PERHAPS COULD HAVE LOST A
COUPLE OF POUNDS.
ACTUALLY, I’M NOT AS HEALTHY,
BUT OTHER PEOPLE ARE HEALTHY.
AGE OF SUCH A BIG FACTOR.
WHEN YOU LOOK IN NEW JERSEY AND
I HAPPEN TO LIKE BUT I GET ALONG
WITH HIM WELL, THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW JERSEY.
GOVERNOR MURPHY.
HE SAID WITH THE THOUSANDS OF
DEATHS, THEY HAD ONE DEATH UNDER
THE AGE OF 18.
AND I BELIEVE THAT YOUNG PERSON
HAD DIABETES.
BUT ONE DEATH OUT OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE.
ONE DEATH.
AND STATISTICS, WE WOULD NOT
HAVE KNOWN THAT AT THE
BEGINNING.
IN ALL FAIRNESS, YOU DIDN’T KNOW
THE ELDERLY WOULD BE SO BADLY
HURT.
SO WE ARE REALLY TAKING CARE OF
THE ELDERLY POPULATION RIGHT
NOW.
AT A LEVEL THAT HAS NEVER
HAPPENED BEFORE.
>> ARE WE GOING TO BEAT THIS
VIRUS?
>> WE ARE GOING TO BEAT IT AND
WE ARE TIMELY GOING TO BE THERE.
OVER TIME IT WILL DISAPPEAR
APPEAR THAT IS TERRIBLE.
IT IS TRUE.
IT WILL DISAPPEAR.
BEFORE IT DISAPPEARS MY THINK WE
CAN KNOCK IT OUT BEFORE IT
DISAPPEARS.
THAT IS WHAT I WANT.
IF I HAD MY CHOICE OF
THERAPEUTICS, GIVE ME
THERAPEUTICS EVERY TIME BECAUSE
I WOULD LOVE TO WALK INTO A
HOSPITAL AND GIVE EVERYBODY
SOMETHING AND THEY START WALKING
OUT IN TWO DAYS.
THAT IS WHAT I LIKE.